>> THE BATTLE ACROSS THE COUNTRY
IN SCHOOLS IS BACK, BUT ONE
MAJOR MEDIA OUTLET HAS DECIDED
WHO'S TO BLAME THE KIDS ARE BACK
IN CLASS THIS FALL.
>> I WANT TO PUT A PIN AND THE
IDEA THAT REPUBLICANS ARE
BLAMING THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
FOR KIDS NOT BEING IN SCHOOL.
IF KIDS AREN'T IN SCHOOL, IT'S
BECAUSE REPUBLICANS DIDN'T GET
VACCINATED OR GOVERNORS STOOD IN
THE WAY OF MASKED MANDATES THAT
WOULD MAKE IT POSSIBLE.
>> Richard: THIS COMES AS THE
CHICAGO TEACHERS UNION HAS SAID
THE DELTA VARIANT COULD DERAIL
PLANS TO RETURN TO IN PERSON
LEARNING THIS FALL.
IT'S WORTH POINTING OUT THAT IN
CHICAGO, TEACHERS ARE GOING DOOR
TO DOOR IN COMMUNITIES WHERE
THEY HAVE LOW VACCINATION RATES,
URGING FAMILIES TO GET
VACCINATED SO THEY CAN MAKE SURE
THEIR SCHOOLS ARE SAFE.
SHANNON, WHAT IS YOUR TAKE?
HOW DO WE GET VACCINATED A
PERSON IN THE WORLD WHERE THE
DELTA VARIANT IS SPREADING?
>> Shannon: ANY TIME YOU START
BLAMING PEOPLE FOR CONTRACTING
AND ILLNESS, THERE'S A LOT OF
SHAMING THAT GOES ALONG WITH
THAT.
IN SAN FRANCISCO, THEY'VE GOT A
HIGH VACCINATION RATES, BUT ALSO
HAVE A SURGE OF CASES.
THOSE ARE REPUBLICANS.
THIS IS GOING TO GET TO PEOPLE
FOR VARIOUS REASONS, INCLUDING
VACCINATED PEOPLE AS WELL.
MY CONFUSION IS WITH THE
TEACHERS UNION.
THEY DEMANDED TO BE AT THE FRONT
OF THE LINE FOR VACCINATIONS,
WHICH WE THOUGHT "THAT'S A GOOD
IDEA, GET THE BACK WITH KIDS
ALONG WITH FIRST RESPONDERS AND
HEALTH CARE WORKERS."
NOW, TEACHERS UNIONS ARE COMING
OUT AND SAYING "YOU CAN'T
MANDATE THAT TEACHERS HAVE TO
GET VACCINATED TO GO BACK."
[LAUGHS]
THERE ARE PLENTY OF PEOPLE, IF
YOU ARE LOOKING TO FIND REASONS
WHY WE MAY NOT GET BACK TO THE
CLASSROOM.
>> Richard: GREG?
>> Greg: "I WANT TO PUT A PIN
IN THE IDEA."
THAT'S MY IMPRESSION OF HER.
[LAUGHTER]
EVERY CULPRIT IN EVERY SEGMENT
IS A REPUBLICAN.
SHE IS THIS ANGRY TEENAGER
GETTING BACK AT HER PARENTS BY
DATING A DRUG DEALER.
IN THIS CASE, IT'S BEING THE
TOWN MASCOT FOR LEFT WING
MASTERS AT MSNBC.
I KNOW THIS WILL HAPPEN IN MY
LIFETIME.
THIS IS A GREAT OPPORTUNITY TO
REMAKE EDUCATION.
THE TEACHERS UNION HAS MADE IT
CLEAR IT'S NOT ABOUT THE KIDS.
IT'S ABOUT THEM.
EVERY REPUBLICAN RUNNING FOR
OFFICE ASKED TO MAKE SCHOOL
CHOICES THEIR NUMBER ONE
PRINCIPAL.
IF YOU SOLVE THAT, EDUCATION,
YOU WILL SOLVE CRIME AND RACISM.
IT'S BUBBLING OUT OF THAT SAME
MESS IN WHICH WE STUPIDLY HANDED
OVER TO UNIONS.
THIS IS THE MOST IMPORTANT THING
IN OUR COUNTRY: EDUCATION.
"I DON'T EVEN LIKE CHILDREN."
WE HAVE ALLOWED THIS TO DK, AND
WE ARE LETTING LUNATICS CONTROL
THIS.
IT'S TIME TO CREATE THE PELLET
TIME MODEL, CHARISMATIC, HIGHLY
PAID TEACHERS, NATIONALIZE IT SO
THEY CAN TEACH AT HOME.
IF YOU WILL BE AT HOME DOING
ZOOM CLASSES, WHEN I GET THE
BEST INSTRUCTORS IN THE WORLD
AND MAKE THEM STARS?
WHY DOES IT HAVE TO BE LOCAL
WESTERN MARK NATIONALIZE IT.
GET RID OF THIS.
>> THE FLORIDA BOARD OF
EDUCATION TODAY WAS HAVING A
MEETING TALKING ABOUT THE
MASKING MANDATE.
YOU KNOW THE POLICY THERE.
THEY WERE TOLD THAT STUDENTS AND
THE MONEY CAN MOVE WITH THEM.
IF PARENTS WANT TO TAKE KIDS OUT
OF SCHOOLS, MONEY CAN FOLLOW
WITH THE KIDS.
THAT'S FOR A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT
ISSUES.
>> Greg: IT'S SPREADING.
IT'S AN AMAZING THING.
>> Richard: DAGAN, THAT'S AN
AMAZING POINT.
WHAT WE ARE SEEING IN TENNESSEE,
THE DIRECTOR OF HEALTH THEY ARE
TALKED ABOUT HOW SHE IS AFRAID
THAT BY NEXT WEEK, THERE WILL BE
NO MORE ICU BEDS AT THE HOSPITAL
BECAUSE OF THE DELTA VARIANT,
AND HER RESPONSE IS ONE OF THE
BEST WAYS TO "SLOW THE SPREAD IS
GO BACK TO SCHOOL FOR CHILDREN,
BY ENSURING KIDS HAVE MASKS ON.
IT'S A SIMPLE THING THEY CAN DO
TO STOP THE SPREAD," IN A WORLD
WHERE SOME CHILDREN CAN'T GET
VACCINATED.
IF YOU WERE 12 AND UNDER, YOU
CAN GET VACCINATED, SO THIS IS A
WAY TO CONTROL THE SPREAD SO WE
DON'T HAVE KIDS IN ICU'S.
>> Dagen: THERE IS NO EVIDENCE
THAT THE DELTA VARIANT IS MORE
SEVERE, PERIOD.
IN EUROPE, THEY DIDN'T MASK KIDS
UNDER THE AGE OF 12, AND THEY
HAD THE SAME OUTCOME.
THEY DID NOT HAVE A WORSE RESULT
THAN THE UNITED STATES.
I WILL QUOTE
"THE NEW YORK POST," AND THIS
PERSON FOR YEAR AND HALF,
THEY'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT THE
DAMAGE THEY'VE DONE TO OUR
CHILDREN BECAUSE OF THESE
POWER-HUNGRY SCIENCE DENIERS.
NOTICE TEACHERS UNIONS THAT
LITERALLY HATE OUR CHILDREN,
HORRIFIC, IRREPARABLE DAMAGE,
EDUCATIONALLY, DEVELOP MENTALLY,
EMOTIONALLY, PSYCHOLOGICALLY.
HERE IS WHAT CAROL SAID.
STUDY AFTER STUDY SHOWED THAT
EVEN ON VACCINATED CHILDREN ARE
SAFER THAN MANY VACCINATED
ADULTS.
KIDS DON'T SPREAD COVID THE SAME
WAY.
SCHOOLS ARE INFECTION HOT SPOTS.
KIDS RARELY GET SICK FROM COVID,
AND WHEN THEY DO, IT'S NO WORSE
THAN A COLD.
INSTEAD, THESE LIBERAL LOWLIFES
IN THE WHITE HOUSE AND THE
EDUCATION SECRETARY AND THE
LIKE, THEY ARE SOFTENING THE
BEACH FOR THESE TEACHERS UNIONS
TO PULL ANOTHER CON JOB ON
AMERICA.
THEY DON'T WANT TO GET BACK TO
WORK.
60% OF TEACHERS IN NEW YORK CITY
NOT VACCINATED, THE LIKES OF
RANDY WEINGART --
>> Richard: BUT YOU WANT
CHILDREN TO GO BACK TO SCHOOL!
>> Dagen: THAT'S A LIE.
THEY HAVE NOT BEEN IN SCOPE FOR
A YEAR AND A HALF IF THAT --
>> Richard: SHE SAID THAT
YESTERDAY!
>> Dagen: -- THE LIVES OF
KIDS.
>> Richard: SHE SAID THAT
YESTERDAY!
>> Dagen: LET ME ADD ONE MORE
THING.
THAT DULL TOOL, SHE'S A BIGOT.
IF SHE IS BLAMING UNVACCINATED
PARENTS FOR THEIR CHILDREN NOT
BEING IN SCHOOL, WHAT ABOUT THE
TWO-THIRDS OF UNVACCINATED BLACK
INDIVIDUALS IN NEW YORK CITY?
AS SHE BLAMING THEM FOR THEIR
REASON THEIR CHILDREN ARE
SUFFERING?
SOMETHING TO THINK ABOUT.
>> Richard: JESSE?
>> Jesse: THIS IS LIKE "THE
REPUBLICANS DEFUNDED THE
POLICE."
SO EASY TO DO.
LET ME TRY THAT.
HERE'S HOW IT WORKS.
[LAUGHTER]
RICHARD, THE DEMOCRATS STORMED
THE CAPITAL ON JANUARY 5TH.
[LAUGHTER]
SHE CAN'T GET AWAY WITH THAT!
WE WON'T LET HER GET AWAY WITH
THAT.
HERE ARE THE LARGEST SCHOOL
DISTRICTS IN THE UNITED STATES.
NEW YORK, CHICAGO, LOS ANGELES,
AND MIAMI.
WHICH SCHOOL DISTRICT WAS OPEN
ALL LAST YEAR, AND WHICH SCHOOL
DISTRICT WILL BE OPEN THIS YEAR
WITH NO MASKS?
MIAMI.
IT'S GOVERNED BY A REPUBLICAN
GOVERNOR, AND IT HAS A
REPUBLICAN MAYOR.
ALL OF THESE OTHER DISTRICTS ARE
RUN BY DEMOCRATS.
IT'S REPUBLICAN ANTI-VECTORS
SPREADING DELTA?
THESE ARE LARGELY
MINORITY/MAJORITY CITIES, 3 TO 1
DEMOCRAT.
THAT'S THE TRUTH.
SHE CAN'T HANDLE IT, RICHARD.
>> Richard: I AGREE.
IN L.A. AND NEW YORK, SAYING WE
NEED MORE SCHOOL NURSES,
LIBRARIANS, SOCIAL WORKERS --